Translator: Joseph Geni
Reviewer: Morton Bast
When I graduated UCLA, I moved to northern California,
and I lived in a little town called Elk
on the Mendocino coast,
and I didn't have a phone or TV, but I had U.S. mail,
and life was good back then, if you could remember it.
I'd go to the general store for a cup of coffee
and a brownie, and I'd ship my film
to San Francisco, and lo and behold, two days later,
it would end up on my front door,
which was way better than having to fight the traffic
of Hollywood. (Music)
I didn't have much money,
but I had time and a sense of wonder. (Music)
So I started shooting time-lapse photography.
It would take me a month to shoot a four-minute
roll of film, because that's all I could afford.
I've been shooting time-lapse flowers continuously,
non-stop, 24 hours a day, seven days a week,
for over 30 years, and to see them move
is a dance I'll never get tired of.
Their beauty immerses us with color, taste, touch.
It also provides a third of the food we eat.
(Music)
Beauty and seduction is nature's tools for survival,
because we protect what we fall in love with.
It opens our hearts, and makes us realize
we are a part of nature and we're not separate from it.
When we see ourselves in nature, it also connects us
to every one of us, because it's clear
that it's all connected in one.
When people see my images, a lot of times they'll say,
"Oh my God." Have you ever wondered what that meant?
The "oh" means it caught your attention,
makes you present, makes you mindful.
The "my" means it connects with something deep
inside your soul.
It creates a gateway for your inner voice to rise up
and be heard. And "God"?
God is that personal journey we all want to be on,
to be inspired, to feel like we're connected to a universe
that celebrates life.
Did you know that 80 percent
of the information we receive comes through our eyes?
And if you compare light energy to musical scales,
it would only be one octave that the naked eye could see,
which is right in the middle?
And aren't we grateful for our brains that can, you know,
take this electrical impulse that comes from light energy
to create images in order for us to explore our world?
And aren't we grateful that we have hearts
that can feel these vibrations
in order for us to allow ourselves to feel the pleasure
and the beauty of nature?
(Music)
Nature's beauty is a gift that cultivates
appreciation and gratitude.
(Music)
So I have a gift I want to share with you today,
a project I'm working on called Happiness Revealed,
and it'll give us a glimpse into that perspective
from the point of view of a child and an elderly man
of that world.
Child: When I watch TV,
it's just some shows that you just -- that are pretend,
and when you explore, you get
more imagination than you already had,
and when you get more imagination,
it makes you want to go deeper in
so you can get more and see beautifuller things,
like the path, if it's a path, it could lead you to a beach,
or something, and it could be beautiful.
(Music)
Elderly Man: You think this is just another day in your life?
It's not just another day. It's the one day that is given to you
today.
It's given to you. It's a gift.
It's the only gift that you have right now,
and the only appropriate response
is gratefulness.
If you do nothing else but to cultivate that response
to the great gift that this unique day is,
if you learn to respond
as if it were the first day in your life
and the very last day,
then you will have spent this day very well.
Begin by opening your eyes and be surprised
that you have eyes you can open,
that incredible array of colors that is constantly offered to us
for pure enjoyment.
Look at the sky.
We so rarely look at the sky.
We so rarely note how different it is
from moment to moment, with clouds coming and going.
We just think of the weather,
and even with the weather, we don't think of
all the many nuances of weather.
We just think of good weather and bad weather.
This day, right now, has unique weather,
maybe a kind that will never exactly
in that form come again.
That formation of clouds in the sky will never be the same
as it is right now.
Open your eyes. Look at that.
Look at the faces of people whom you meet.
Each one has an incredible story behind their face,
a story that you could never fully fathom,
not only their own story, but the story of their ancestors.
We all go back so far,
and in this present moment, on this day,
all the people you meet, all that life from generations
and from so many places all over the world
flows together and meets you here
like a life-giving water, if you only open your heart and drink.
(Music)
Open your heart to the incredible gifts that civilization
gives to us.
You flip a switch and there is electric light.
You turn a faucet and there is warm water and cold water,
and drinkable water.
It's a gift that millions and millions in the world
will never experience.
So these are just a few of an enormous number of gifts
to which we can open your heart.
And so I wish you that you will open your heart
to all these blessings, and let them flow through you,
that everyone whom you will meet on this day
will be blessed by you,
just by your eyes,
by your smile,
by your touch,
just by your presence.
Let the gratefulness overflow
into blessing all around you,
and then it will really be a good day. (Music)
(Applause)
Louie Schwartzberg: Thank you.
Thank you very much. (Applause)